よろしくお願いします
それからブッダの精神解剖学というテーマで話します
この今日の話はまあ子供でも聞いてれば簡単に理解できる
そんなに難しいことではないんです
で まあ聞いて理解すれば頭が良くなるだけの話ですけど
まあこれは大変だと思ったら聞かなくてもいいです
で 生命の仕組み で 幻想の分析
幻想を分析する教えですね
仏教っていうのは 現象っていうのはもういろんなものをバラしてバラして分析してみるんです
で 見ただけで聞いただけで実態はわからない
ね 何か見ただけでわかるわけじゃないでしょうに
で 例えば下から上見るとものすごい硬い雲があるような見えますけど
まあ飛行機でも乗って上見てみれば
ただの霧だけで別に曇っているものはあるわけじゃないし
で まあ聞いただけで何かそのものをその通りであるともわからないし
ですから それではまあ実態
本当の状態はわからないんです
で 何もかも徹底的に分析してみる
仏教はなんでもバラしちゃうんですね
徹底的に はい そこで極限にバラしたところで
一つ一つのユニットが互いにどのように関係を持つのかと調べる
まず何でもいいんだから
もうできるだけ分けて分けて分けて分けて
分解して分解してで見るんです
おもちゃでもただそのままあるとなんかすごい面白そうなんですけど
分解して分解してみると
もうなんでどうやってできているのかってことをわかってくれますし
だからどんなものでも分解してみれば
バラしてみればまあわかるということで
仏教はそれだけでは足らんのだから
もう徹底的に分解する
分解してからその最後に出てきた小さな小さなもの
その小さなユニット これがこれと何の関係あるのかどうか
どうやってつなげていたのかとかね
そういうふうにそれ調べてみるんですね
よって ありのままの真理を発見する
それで本当のことをわかってくるんです
我々が思ったことではなくて
考えたことではなくて
まあまあみんな言ってることではなくて
本当のことは何なのかと
自分があれが好きや これが好きやと自分の好みで物事を考えているんですね
人間というのは で そういうことではなくて
ただみんな言ってるんだからといって
また何のことなく信じ込んじゃうんですね
で そうではなくて 釈尊お釈迦様がおっしゃるのは
ありのまま 本当のことを知りなさいよと
だから本当のことを知るためには
やっぱりもう徹底的に物事をバラしてみなきゃできないし
それからお互いにどうやって関係を持っているのかっていうことも見なくちゃいけないんです
テーラワーダ伝統によると
ブッダはヴィパッジャワーディだそうです
これは一応記録されていることで
ブッダは何を得る人ですかと
で あのお釈迦様が亡くなって
まあ一応えっとえっと
えっとえっと まあ百年じゃなくて
百年ぐらい経ったところで
で かなりみんなお互いに仏教はバラバラになっちゃって
十八種類の宗派ができて
もう大変なことになっていたんです
その時はアショーカ帝王ってインドを統一した王がいて
で 彼が仏教になりまして
それでお坊さんたちから仏教を学んで
で しかし なんでみんなゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャいろんなことをやっているのかということで
これは改良し 改善しなくちゃ改革しなくちゃいけないんだということで
大阿羅漢モッガリプッタという大阿羅漢を呼んで
議長として置いておいて
自分がいろんな仏教 仏教と名乗っている人々に聞くんですよ
ブッダはインタビューするんです
ブッダは何をおっしゃってる人ですだと思いますかと
そうすると みんな自分自分の考え方を言うんです
特にアショーカ帝王の時代では
ものすごいお寺を作ったりして
八万四千にもお寺を作ったと言いますからね
今もありますからね ものすごい巨大な寺とか作ったりして
だからかなり仏教はもう経済的にというかね
豊かになっていたんですね
それでみんな簡単に食べていられるんで
簡単にもう金持ちになるんだぞということで
いろんな人が入ったのは入ったんですけど
別に仏教を学ぶということはしない
ただ財産管理ばっかりやっている
信者さんがお布施して置いておくものをそのまま自分のものにして
それでまあまあお寺もすごい巨大になってきましたし
そういうものは財産管理ばっかりやっていて
そこで初期仏教のお坊さんたちは財産を触ることもしないし
このお寺にいて修行して
また別なお寺に行ったりとかね
そこでそういうお寺は自分のものにして止まっていて
もう財産にしがみついている人々はいたんですね
その人々はもう話すことはわからんだから
仏教はわからへんだから
みんなにも拝むことやら祈祷することやら
もっともっとこの仏塔にもっともっとお布施しなさいとか
そうすると子宝に恵まれますよとか
なんだかんだくだらんことばっかり言い出していたんですよ
で そういうことだから
アショーカ帝王が個人一人一人であんた
ブッダが何を教える人だと思いますか？と言うといろんなことを言うんだそうです
そこでブッダはもう分析好き者やと
物事を全部全部分けて分けてばらして
実体はないということを説く人やという人々を止まってもらって
他の人々にお金あげて還俗させちゃったんだそうです
ものすごい大量の人々
あんた方は仏教徒ではないんだと
自分たちの宗教を信仰しなさいと
それでもまあ出ていかなかった人々はまた固めて
宗派として固めていて
どんどんどんどん あとほんのちょっと時間経つと
まあ年ぐらい経つと そこら辺でいわゆる今現代いう大乗仏教と思想体系とかまあ現れてきたんです
だからこのヴィパッサナーでっていうことは
伝統の中では結構有名なことで
ブッダは分析するんだよと
何でも 次出すのです で
しかしブッダは合成も極力に極力語られました
まあ分析主義者といっても
経典を読んでみると 物事はどうやって合成するのか
どうやって現れるのかということもものすごい教えているんです
だから 一概にブッダは分析主義者というのは
私個人的には正しいとは思わないんです
しかし 我々のテーラワーダ伝統は
ブッダは分析主義者やと思っているんです
それからこの方法論 どうやって分析するのかと
ものを極限に最小のユニットまで分解する
なんでも分解してみます
まあ一番わかりやすい例で言えば
この人間というのは 私はかっこいいんだとか思っているでしょうに
私は綺麗だ かっこいいものだとか
それでお釈迦様は ではこの肉体を分解してみなさいと
何があるのかと そうすると目があったり
皮膚があったり 歯があったり
髪の毛があったり 体の毛があったり
それは別々にしてイメージしてみなさいと
髪の毛は別にしてイメージしてみる
歯を抜いた状態で抜かれた状態で歯は別にしてイメージしてみる
骨組みを別にして見ると
気持ち悪くていられなくなっちゃうんです
心臓 腎臓 胆臓 肝臓とかね
大腸 小腸 大便 小便 血液
それも別々で見てみると
血液なんか見たらほとんどみんなもう頭が怖くなってなるでしょうに
ただずっと自分の体の中に流れているものなんですけど
そうやって分解して見たら
私ってすごいかっこいいやと言って言えたところでなくなっちゃうんです
あの人 この人 あの人 美しい
この人美しくないってそんなことが言える状態でなくなっちゃうんです
みんな同じ不浄な三十二のものでできているんだということで心が明らかになるんです
そういうふうに いろんなところで分解のやり方使ってます
そのユニットのスペシフィックキャラクタリスティックというもの
日本語で言えば特質ですね
とジェネラルキャラクタリスティックという普遍性を見いだす
そこで小さなものに分解して
これ自身が何を持っている特色を持っているのか
これ この部品とこの部品が共通して何を持っているのかという 2つを探すんです
まあ簡単ですよ 例えば機械をバラしちゃう
バラしちゃうとネジありますね
ネジを見たら このネジだけの仕事は何なのかというと
他のものをつなげていることなんです
他の仕事をしない それは特色なんですね
でもネジといっても よく見ると同じネジをつける板がありますからね
それも同じ部品でできているかもしれません
同じ品物で 同じ金属で
あるいはプラスチックの板にプラスチックのネジをつけるとかね
そういう まあ似ているものも発見する
例えばネジは4種類あると
仕事は４つなんですね
このネジはちょっと重いところは捕まっておくと
これはすごく軽いところは捕まっておくと
と特色が見えてくる しかし
全部同じものでできているんだ
そういう 2つを発見しなくちゃいけないんですね
specific characteristicというものとgeneral characteristicというものですね
で それで両面まとめて仏教では本質
本性 法性 法相といういろいろ用語が出てきます
大体この大乗仏教に出てくる単語なんですが
この特質と普遍性 まとめてつけてる言葉なんです
それはまとめて言葉をつけられないはずですけど
そのまとめたところでものすごい大変なことになってしまったんです
後で それはテーラワーダ仏教でできたではありません
一応 大乗経典 大乗仏教でいろいろ見ると
本質という言葉が出てくる
本性 法性 ダンマラークシャナ
で ダンマ・スバーハー法相という
サンスクリット語でそれぞれ別な言葉がありますけど
そういう言葉で言うんですね
パーリ語で これはスバーハーラッカーナという言葉なんですね
まとめた言葉 で もろもろのユニットが互いに依存し合って現象を合成する機能を踏まえた上でまた続きます
存在について結論に至る
それにもろもろのユニットが
例えばもう小さな小さな部品
部品じゃなくて 最初の単位のものを発見したら
それぞれどうやって互いに関係を持っているのかと
で それで例えば太陽があるんですね
太陽といっても まあ聞いたところで
なんかガスの塊なんですね
見たことはないんですけど
何ガスでしたっけ？水素
水素といえばそんな大胆なことではありませんけど
それがお互いにいろいろ働きかけちゃって
そこでも太陽としてすごい燃えているんですね
それだけじゃなくて あらゆるものが太陽から出てくるんですよ
あらゆる放射線であろうか
いろんなもの もうほとんどもう地球にあるものというのは
太陽から出されたものみたいな感じなんですね
しかし もともと見れば
もう水素 お互いに融合してすることで現れる出来事なんですね
で それで私は今 人間でいうと男であると
こんな年であると 体形こういうこういうものであるとの現象なんですね
あの人は背が低い あの人は背が高い
あの人は体が大きい この花は黄色い黄色い色で綺麗
あの花はもう色はいいんだけど
あまり形は良くないとかね
それは我々の現象の世界
人間に見える世界 しかし
本当の世界はそうと違うんです
なんで赤くなったのかと
どんな成分がこの花を赤にしたんでしょうかと
どんな成分がこの花は黄色い色にしたんでしょうかと
それを探さなくちゃあかんですね
そうするとそういうものを探してどうやって合成するのかと
それで考えたから お釈迦様は次の
存在について結論に至る
じゃあ生きるということはこういうものであるとお釈迦様はそれで結論するんです
存在するすべては無常である
一番小さなものから見ると
なんだ 一つも止まらなく変化するものなんですね
だったらまとめてみたっても変化するんだよと
すぐ死んじゃうものをたくさんまとめて何か作っても
そのものも死んでしまっちゃうんですよ
そういう結論に至ったんですね
存在するすべては空しい
無意味 それは苦であると
存在 存在って何のことない
もうただ変化するもので
意味がないということで
苦とドゥッカと言うんですね
次の結論は いかなる場合でもなんですけど
これは読めないんですけど
まあ一応もう勝手な感じ入れたんですけどね
常営というかね いわゆる常にあるというものはね
一定不変の特性を持つ実体はない
いかなるもの どんなもの場合でも
絶対変わらない何かあるわけじゃないんだと
全部変わるんだよとお釈迦様は発見するんですね
実体がない それをアナッターと言うんです
無我とも言うんです それがお釈迦様に至った結論なんです
はい 存在に存在に執着することにより
悩み苦しみが生まれる
そこで我々は捕まらなくてもいいものを
ただの空しいなのに変わっていくのに
ああ欲しいとか執着するんです
だからシャボン玉が欲しいやと思うことと同じなんです
持っていこうと持っていけるわけじゃない
そこでシャボン玉を大事に持って家に持って帰ろうと思ったっても
大変な苦労をしなくちゃいけないんです
苦労したっても 必ずもうちょっとしたことで弾けて消えてしまうんですね
それでああ ああしまったという感じになっちゃうんです
そこで我々は品物であろうか
もうこれが欲しい あれが欲しいとかね
まあ執着する自分に対しても
自分にすごい自分のこと好きなんですね
それで結局いろんなものを変化していく
よく勉強できる自分がもうかっこいいやと思っていたところで
もう頭がおかしくなって勉強できなくなって
点数が減っちゃうと もう気分が悪くなっちゃって落ち込んだりもする
そういうどんなものでもこの執着するんだから現れちゃうんですね
たまたままあもう隣の子供の答案をカニングして
でも自分も 90点とか取ったところで
まあまあ我ながら結構頭がいいやと威張ったりもするし
それで次はできなくなっちゃうし
そういういろんなものに我々執着してすぐひどい目にあっちゃうんですね
だからすべてはシャボン玉のように
もう 弾けて弾けていくものなのに
みんな分析しないんだから
それわからない だから執着して苦しむんだよと
だから前に言ったドッカの苦と一番最後に言う苦しみっていうのは少々違うんです
この今の最後に言う存在に執着することのよりことにより生まれる苦しみっていうのは悩み
苦しみは我々感じる苦しみなんですよ
悲しいとか大変だとかね
つまらないとか それと恐怖感とかね
これでこんなもんでいいのでしょうか
将来どうなるんでしょうかとかね
もうあらゆる人間感じる苦難が生まれるんです
上へ行ってる苦はものすごい厳密な真理の苦なんです
しかし お釈迦様はあえて同じ言葉にしているんです
それはまあすごいすごいわけがあって
同じ言葉を使っているんです
はい そんなもんです 結論は
存在は執着するに値するものではない
自分自身も世界も執着するに値するものじゃない
もうシャボン玉だよと
シャボン玉に執着するのは意味がないでしょうに
その瞬間で綺麗やと思っても
まあいいやと弾けたっても
我々シャボン玉で遊ぶ時は
いくらシャボン玉を弾けて弾けていたっても
別に悲しくはないんです
しかし それがあってほしいと
お父さん見て見てとお父さんに見せようとしたところで
もうすぐ弾けちゃうと
その瞬間で子供はあーっというふうに思っちゃうんですね
なぜかというと 自分が綺麗なシャボン玉を作って
それはお父さん見るまで持ちたくなる
持ちたくなるんです その瞬間であっという気持ちになっちゃうんですよ
だから弾けるものは弾けるんだよと思ってもらわないと
人間は苦しむんです はい
この真理を知る人の心が自由になれる
で 解放される すごい自由になりますよ
自分も世界も全部シャボン玉で弾けて弾けていくものだとわかったら
はい これが最高な幸福である
それ以外幸福 本物の幸福っていうのはないんです
パーリ語でニッバーナパラマンスカンと言うんですね
意味は涅槃 悟りは究極な幸福であるという
涅槃ニッバーナっていうのは
この心が自由になったこと
どうやって自由になるのかというと
全部シャボン玉やと 私もすべてのものもシャボン玉みたいなもので
一時的にちょっと現れる
幻覚として それだけのことではないかとよく悟ることなんですね
そこで聖なる八正道がありまして
この聖という漢字を使うのは
そこら中の人が言っているものじゃないんだという意味なんです
これは超越した智慧で
ブッダの学者たるブッダの悟りの智慧で語られているんだから
軽視するんじゃないよと
なめるんじゃないよということで
これに勝る真理はないということで強調するために
ブッダ自身の教えにすべて聖というお釈迦様自身がつけるんです
この聖なる八正道を歩めば
この状態を成就するんです
だからすべて無常だとわかるためには
八正道という実践方法がありまして
それをやらないとわからないんですね
はい それで結論が終わったと思います
それでまあ方法論 それから本文に入ります
もうわかりましたね もうそれ単純でしょ
でもう一度繰り返すのは
例えば我々ボールペンだという
ボールペンって何なのかと
バラすんですよ バラしてみると
キャップがありまして
なんか丸い芯みたいなものがあって
中もインク入ってる 芯があって
かける鉄の鉄でできている
ほんの何かあって それそれさらにさらにバラバラしてみると
あら ボールペンってどうなったんでしょうかと
ボールペンというものはなくなっちゃうんです
ボールペンという実体がなくなっちゃう
ボールペンはどこにあるのかというと
どこにもないんです それで合成すると
一時的にボールペンということが成り立つんです
分解しちゃうと 別な名前
別な働きするんですよ
あのボールペンのこのボディの方がボールペンとしてるともう握るものなんです
それバラしちゃうと もう握る
握られないわけじゃないんだけど
別なことでもできる そこであの
あの管の中にインクがある場合は
ちゃんと芯の鉄のあの前の先っぽのところもついていると
書けますが それだけでは書けませんね
もう曲がっちゃいます
だからもう硬い何かの中に入れてもらわないと
それでそれ外して あの管の中にあるインクは外に出してみたらどうでしょうかというと
もうどうにもならん 別のはたらき汚すだけ
その場合は手に入れたら手は手は汚れ
汚れるは服に落ちたら服が汚れる
汚れるものなんですよ
しかし ボールペンとしていると
あのインクはちゃんと文字を書ける
別な仕事をするんですね
そういうふうに理解するんですよ
物事は だからバラしていけばいくほど
仕事まで変わっていくんです
そこでとことんとことんバラしていくんです
ギリギリなところまで
そうしちゃうと もう我々の考え方
考えているものというのはどんどん変わっていく
例えばボールペンにしたっても
あのなんとかすごい高いものありますね
いろんなメーカーの商品とかね
まあ何でも 100円で 3本売ってるわけではないんですよ
もう10万円のボールペンもあります
100円に 3本もらうものもあります 100
円ショップで そこですごい高い高価なボールペンにしたって
これはもう 18 金でできてるんだよって言うんです
だから10万円だよと
その価値があるのはもう組み立ててる時だけなんです
それも中にある芯を出してみると
あのプラスチックじゃなくてアルミ製でできているだけの差で
インク入ってるのはアルミ製の管なんです
これは何の価値もないんですよ
それを持っていって 外して
インクをきれいに捨てて
あの書けるポインターというところも捨てちゃって
まあこれはあの それでもしかすると分解したら16分の1で分解したとしましょう
10分の1に分解したとしますよ
そうすると10万円だから
もう1万円でしょ 一部品は
では売ってみましょう
あのアルミの管は これ1万円で買ってくれないかと
もう怒られるだけでしょうに
1円でも誰も買ってくれない
そこであの握るところ
ボールペンのボディというもの
それは 18 金でできてますけど
だから金として売れるかというと売れないんです
中またいろいろ価値のないものを入れて合成して作っているんです
ではキャップを売れますか？と聞く
売れないんですよ 分解したら10万円はすぐもう価値がないというものになってしまうんです
だからまあ仕事変わっちゃうんですよ
だからそれで仏教では自分をことごとく分解して
一個一個はどんな仕事をするものかと
何が価値あるのかと調べてみると
何の価値もないということを発見できる
それはドゥッカということで
空ということで で よく変わるものやとわかるし
それは無常ということで
なんだ私という実体がないんじゃないのかと
なんだボールペンという実体がないんじゃないかと
ただ一時的に組み立てたところであらわれる現象のみであるとわかるんです
そういう合成は方法論なんですね